are your parents proud of you yeah they
are no they are my grandma definitely is
my dad my dad it took him a while but
now he's like but now like I added him
to my family play on oh you know he's
riding the pony a little what did he
want for you and you were younger he
wanted me to be completely mediocre like
I'm you know government job meat
inspector he didn't really he never he
wasn't the agent parent like wanted me
to be a doctor he wanted me to be like
the guy who like the preps you before
your mammogram you know what I mean
tech like the tech yeah where are you
going the sub one likes a boy he wanted
something reliable yeah like yeah like
it's something practical yeah um yeah he
didn't yeah he wasn't really would but
you went to a performing arts high
school all right I did yeah so didn't
couldn't he at least say that hey maybe
this is where she's headed or maybe this
is what she's interested in I think he
was okay with it at the time because it
was a good school but um um I mean oh
yeah like Asian parents don't [ __ ]
they're weird I think what they really
just want for you is to be able able to
take care of yourself you know and not
have to worry about you and they died
yeah but some of it staged [ __ ]
though - yeah
that's Korean [ __ ] yeah yeah chosen
choice you go to Harvard
right meanwhile I'm in my second or drug
rehab right my junior in high school
right and like I'm getting all apps
right Oh David oh my god
it's family so happy I'm
right I'm staying there with [ __ ]
needle marks in my arm I'm on TV doubt
yeah you know what I mean that's what I
say when people compare me well now what
happened was you're my dad you saw me on
um I did Jay Leno in the stand-up in
2000 1999 Wow and I go watch it they go
no you're not gonna be on like I'm gonna
be on no didn't don't have I go yeah and
I went on I crushed it right
yeah and they saw it yeah and then the
next day they were both crying and they
felt guilt for all those years of not
supporting me and I wrestled it if I
could just if I could see that go
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know the
[ __ ] seven years of open nut my
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] not kill you but you
know what it takes for them they have to
see like my dad my dad saw me on the
cover of New York magazine on his own oh
we weren't even talking cuz he was so
mad that I was doing this and then that
happened and his coworker he like went
to his car wasn't that's my daughter and
he's covered Rosie oh your daughter's
Aquafina
he was like a young Korean guy yeah so
until then like he realizes [ __ ]
then he called you know yeah we our
relationship was really bad until I
think he realized that it was I was
gonna make it work somehow yep is that
fair to us no no that's you know I mean
they're being dicks like we're not gonna
support your even I don't think from
that place either it's just cuz that's
survival mentality where it's like they
they only know how to do it the way they
did it which is you get this job I mean
for me it was my mom you know it's like
you be a nurse or you're basically gonna
be a homeless person yeah like there is
no other she doesn't have an imagination
beyond yeah yeah they don't and I think
that's because they see I mean it was
your mom did your mom an immigrant
mm-hmm yeah I think when you're an
immigrant
see how yours you have to survive here
so you know you only know a couple of
ways but
[Music]